[Music]
is there any way we can increase our
chances for a long and healthy life dr.
Joel Wallach explains why most chronic
and degenerative diseases are
preventable
through proper nutrition you'll learn
why people in certain cultures
throughout our world typically live well
over 120 years with almost no incidence
of cancer heart disease diabetes or
other common illnesses that shorten
human life you'll also learn the vital
role that minerals play in maintaining
our health and why our modern diets are
sorely lacking in these life-sustaining
nutrients listen now to a live
presentation by a man who is making a
major impact in the field of alternative
medicine dr. Joel Wallach well I'm
certainly glad you're here how many of
you grew up on a farm or still work a
farm or have anything dude livestock
well I'll tell you what you're my kind
of people
because I grew up on a farm in West st.
Louis County and we start out with beef
calves and if you raise livestock the
only way to make money is if you raise a
lot of your own feed for those of you
don't have that experience and so we
raised our own corn and we raised our
own soybeans in our own hay and we had a
truck come out from the mill and this
truck would come out from the mill and
it would grind up the corn and the
soybeans and the hay and then we would
add sacks of vitamins minerals trace
minerals and we make pellets out of it
and this is what we would feed the
calves in six months time we'd ship them
to market to be slaughtered we'd say
back some of the best ones for herself
we'd knock him in the head kneed him put
it bluntly and it always fascinated me
as a teenager that we did that for those
calves and then six months ship them off
to be slaughtered or we'd eat them and
we wanted to live to be a hundred years
of age without any aches and pains and
guess what we didn't take any vitamins
or minerals and that bothered me so I
asked my dad I'd say hey pops how come
you do that for those calves you don't
do that for us and he'd give me this
good old Missouri farm wisdom he'd say
things like shut up boy you're getting
this farm fresh food and we hope you
appreciate it
and of course I was very quiet then
because I didn't want to miss out on any
meals well then when I went to school I
went to the University of Missouri
School of Agriculture and I got my
degree in agriculture I got my major and
animal husbandry in nutrition my minor
was in field crops and soils and then I
got into veterinary school as a freshman
veterinary student I've learned to
answer to my question and the answer is
this we know how to prevent and cure
diseases and animals with nutrition and
the reason why we do that is because we
don't have major medical we don't have
hospitalization BlueCross BlueShield we
don't have Medicare if you're gonna make
money as a farmer you better know how to
do stuff yourself and you better do it
efficiently with feed and nutrition if
you can to make a long story short after
I got out of veterinary school I went to
Africa for two years and I was able to
fulfill a boyhood dream I was able to be
a Frank buck for two years and worked
with Marlin Perkins many of you will
remember him from the mutual of Omaha's
Wild Kingdom and he's a great gentleman
and after two years of working with
elephants and rhinos people used to ask
me or are you a small animal vet or a
large animal vet while I was telling my
man extra large animal vet because I
worked with elephants and rhinos well
after two years he sent me a telegram
and said would you come back to the st.
Louis Zoo and work with us we need a
wildlife veterinarian at the zoo for a
special project we were given a seven
and a half million dollar grant from the
National Institutes of Health and what
we need is a veterinarian who'll do
autopsies of animals that died of
natural causes in the zoo I was just
overjoyed to do that and so I came back
and and of course I not only did
autopsies for animals that died in the
st. Louis Zoo but the Brookfield Zoo in
Chicago the Bronx Zoo in New York the
National Zoo the LA Zoo and so forth and
my job again was to do autopsies of
animals that died of natural causes in
the zoo and look for a species of
animals it was ultra sensitive to
pollution this is because during the
early 60s we had just learned about
pollution and ecological problems and
disasters and nobody quite knew what to
do and so I was supposed to find a
species of animals it was extra
sensitive and used them much like we did
the Canaries in the mine you're the old
Welsh coal miners used to put a canary
in a little wicker cage and take it down
in the mine
of methane gas or carbon monoxide would
leak into the mind the canary would drop
off the perch and die first and the man
knew to get out before the mine blew up
or they suffocated again to make a long
story short over a period of some 12
years I did 17,500 autopsies and over
four hundred and fifty four species of
animals and 3,000 human beings who lived
in close proximity to zoos and the thing
that I found out was this every animal
and human being who dies of natural
causes dies of a nutritional deficiency
and that fascinated me I went back took
me back to those cows I said gee that's
fascinating we could document this at
autopsy both chemically and
biochemically and things you saw with
the eye at the autopsy table
well that fascinated me I wrote
scientific articles I wrote eight
multi-author textbooks in one textbook
of my own cause one hundred and forty
bucks for medical students and I'm sure
the only thing they do is use them for
doorstops and it couldn't get anybody
excited I was on 20/20 I was on 1,700
newspapers I was in magazines it was in
every network TV that you can think of
and guess what
couldn't get anybody excited back in the
60s about nutrition so what I did was
went back to school and became a
physician to use everything I'd learned
in veterinary school about nutrition of
my human patients and to no surprise to
me it worked
spent 12 years up in Portland Oregon and
general practice and it's very
fascinating what I'm going to share with
you tonight is what I learned over those
1012 years using nutrition with my human
patients and if you take home only 10%
it will save you an enormous amount of
unnecessary misery it will save you a
gob of money and those of you in
Missouri know what that means a gob
means a lot okay it will add many
healthful years to your life well you
can't do this you can't get these
healthful years you can't have longevity
you can't live to your genetic potential
just falling off a stump you have to do
some things and the first thing I have
to do is convince you that it is worth
doing these things I'm going to start
out by convincing you that the genetic
potential for human beings is
hundred and twenty years our genetic
potential for longevity in May eleventh
the oldest living American at this time
and documented through the Guinness
World Book of Records was Margaret skeet
she was from Radford Virginia she died
at age 115 and she died of a nutritional
deficiency you can tell that from her
obituary as she died at the
complications of a fall what did she die
from osteoporosis very good she died of
a calcium deficiency she had no heart
disease no cancer no diabeetus no other
infirmities but she died three weeks
after a fall because she didn't have
enough calcium her daughter said that
she had a craving for sweets until she
died and that's a disease called pica
we'll talk about that a little bit but
usually when you have a craving for
chocolate if you're a chocoholic or a
sugar or holic that means that you have
a deficiency if then in a third world
country and Niger in Africa a chief by
the name of Bauer at age 126 was
eulogized by one of his wives and she
was bragging about him at his death at
age 126 he was still in possession of
all his own teeth okay so you assume
that other faculties are working too
then here's a gentleman from Syria at
age 133 he died in July of 1993 he
fathered nine children after the age of
80 and this meant if you add up nine
months for each child in a year for
breastfeeding for each one and a year
between each one of the children he was
still fathering children after age of a
hundred so there's still hope for you
fellows then those of you who like
science in November of 1993 those six
biosphere Ian's came out of that dome in
Arizona they were in there for two years
three couples and they were supposed to
eat the perfect food and recycle the
atmosphere and grow their own food and
whatnot and have no pollution in their
water or air or food and when they came
out there examined by medical
gerontologist from UCLA University of
California Los Angeles they put all this
information their physical their blood
work and so forth into the medical
computers at UCLA and the medical
computers projected that they
could live to be a hundred and
sixty-five years old if they continue to
do what they were doing so all of that
just says to you that there's a there's
a possibility you can live to be a
hundred and twenty and when I grew up on
the farm we could grow two hundred
bushels of corn per acre and with all
the labor and all the fertilizer and
everything else you did you could make a
profit if you grew two hundred bushels
per acre but if you only got a hundred
bushels per acre and put out that same
effort in the same fertilizer cost you'd
lose money and so I want you to think
about it the average lifespan for an
American today is seventy five point
five the average lifespan for an MD or a
doctor is 58 you want to gain 20 years
statistically just don't go to medical
school you want to live to be 120
there's only two basic things that real
simple two things remember number one
you have to avoid the pitfalls you have
to not step on the landmines I call it
and those of you in the military you
know that means you do something stupid
like step on one of those things you
kill yourself wastefully or
unnecessarily and of course if you play
Russian roulette or smoke excessively or
drink excessively or wear a black
sweatshirt and run down the middle of
the highway at two o'clock in the
morning you're gonna get struck by a car
all of those things are foolhardy but
it's amazing how many tens of thousands
of people die in America from doing
those stupid things every year the last
thing I will share with you on that
subject of avoiding the landmines
I'd suggest very strongly to you that
you avoid going to doctors and I'm going
to back up that statement which is a
pretty strong statement from ralph
nader's group in January of 1993 just
about a year and a half ago January 13th
he put out a news release based on a
3-year study on the causes of death in
American hospitals and it was fifteen
hundred page report this three year
study and I'm not going to waste your
time or mine by going over the whole
thing word for word but the bottom line
says a lot quote 300,000 Americans are
killed each year in hospitals alone as a
result of medical negligence unquote I'm
going to read that figure again because
it's a huge figure quote 300,000
Americans are killed each year in
hospitals alone as a result of medical
negligence
unquote he didn't say slipped away
quietly out of neglect and
somewhere while they're waiting for an
x-ray he is the word killed when you
used the word killed that means there
was a procedure the doctor was doing
went wrong somehow that means that they
gave them a wrong prescription they put
a decimal point in the wrong spot and
gave them an incorrect dosage these
people were killed 300,000 to appreciate
how big a figure that is you have to
compare that with our military losses in
Vietnam over ten years where we lost
fifty six thousand people over ten years
or an average of only five thousand six
hundred a year on a field of battle
where people had guns and artillery and
explosives trying to kill each other and
millions of people poured out into the
streets and protested that war we had
political anarchy in the last three
years of the war students took over
universities and colleges with guns and
explosives National Guardsmen shot
students at Kent State in Ohio we chased
a president out of the presidency for
5,600 military personnel year and here's
one profession that takes your tax money
in the form of Medicare and Medicaid and
kills 300,000 of us a year according to
Ralph Nader and I believe he me as no
axe to grind and you can go out on the
street any day of the week in any city
and there isn't even a crazy street
preacher out there with a sign that says
protect us from doctors I want you to
think about that folks that's number one
you have to avoid stepping on the
landmines so there's a certain value and
treating yourself when you can while
preventing disease they don't have to
get treated now the second thing you
have to do number two is you have to do
the positive things you have to do the
positive things and I'm going to start
out here by just putting a figure up on
the board it's the number ninety and you
need 90 nutrients in your diet every day
you need 60 minerals you need sixteen
vitamins you need twelve essential amino
acids or protein building blocks and you
need three essential fatty acids you
need 90 nutrients in your daily diet
otherwise you're gonna get a deficiency
disease if you don't have them in
complete numbers and optimal amounts I
can tell you that I was one of those
nerds back when I was in college I had a
clipboard we didn't have computers back
then so I had a clipboard and I was one
of those funny guys with glass
and would walk up and down in the
Student Union there in Colombia and say
do you take vitamins and minerals I'm
still fascinated by that and and of
course people kind of look at you're
crazy and say well yeah I take vitamin E
and I'd wait for him to come up with the
other 89 and they didn't they just so I
take vitamin E well today if you ask
people do you take food supplements they
say oh yeah I take tums because that's
what you know they hear all the time
well again you need 90 nutrients if
you're going to make it but the
newspaper is no and then magazines and
TV and radio knows that were interested
in health and longevity and and
supplements so they all talk to us not
because the medical profession has asked
them to do that in their stead the
medical profession doesn't say hey we're
so busy saving people with surgery and
chemotherapy and radiation and
pharmaceuticals would you please educate
the people on nutrition they do it
because it sells newspapers well my
favorite article of all time appeared in
Time magazine April 6th 1992 and if you
haven't read it I'd urge you to get it
out of the school library or public
library and photocopy it stick one copy
on the door in the bathroom and one on
the refrigerator it's a cover article
and it says the real power of vitamins
new research shows they may help fight
cancer heart disease and the ravages of
aging again there's six positive pages
in here there's only one negative
sentence and was issued by a medical
doctor who is asked by the writer of the
article what do you think what do you
think about vitamins and minerals for
people is food supplements and here's
what the doctor said quote popping
vitamins doesn't do you any good sniffs
dr. Victor Herbert a professor of
medicine at New York City's Mount Sinai
Medical School we get all the vitamins
we need in our diets and taking
supplements just gives you expensive
urine unquote well to give you a
Missouri translation of that that means
you're just peeing away your dollars if
you take vitamins and minerals you might
as well wad up your dollars and throw
them in the toilet and flush them away
because you're not getting any redeeming
value from it those quacks are just
taking your money for those vitamins and
minerals that's what he was trying to
say got published so it must be true
right after having done those 17,500
autopsies and 454 species of animals
from around the world and then 3,000
humans and liking to be healthy myself
and having children and grandchildren in
the not-too-distant future great ranch
and I'd rather pee out 50 cents or a
dollar day worth of excess vitamins and
minerals is pretty cheap insurance if
you don't invest in yourself to the tune
of a buck a day for vitamins and
minerals guess what you're gonna invest
in the lifestyle of an MD somewhere
because when you pay the medical doctor
your fee for going to see him not one
penny of that goes to study how to
diagnose or treat or prevent a
catastrophic disease and a little child
like who is in here earlier or how to
prevent or diagnose or treat better
breast cancer prostate cancer in adults
guess what that money goes for our pays
the doctor's mortgage makes his Mercedes
payment it pays the tuition for his kids
to go to medical school at have it you
know have it is up and Basten pays it
tuition for his kids to go to law school
at Yale between 1776 in the Second World
War the US government spent 80 million
dollars on health care and health care
research and studies right now we're 1.2
trillion dollars a year for health care
and it's free we all know it's free
right it's not free but we're supposed
to believe it's free and everybody wants
more of it and more free stuff well tell
you what if we used a human-type medical
system for the agricultural industry and
the livestock your hamburger caused 275
dollars a pound on the other hand if you
use the agricultural health system that
we use in animals for humans your
monthly insurance premiums for a family
of five would be ten dollars a month you
take your choice well I believe since
we've made them wealthy through
insurance programs and government
subsidies
I believe they owe us something I
believe they owe us at least as much as
the industry's do according to for
instance recall notices this was started
of course I don't know 25 years ago when
Ralph Nader learned that the Ford Motor
Company had made a Pinto car with a rear
end gas tank that would blow up when you
got hit from behind at 20 miles an hour
fry everybody in the car and when people
complain to Ford Motor Company they said
well you're just dumb for getting in a
car accident we're not going to pay you
for that well Ralph Nader says no it's a
faulty design so he went to a federal
court and the judge agreed with him and
through a court order
forced ford motor company to send
everybody a recall notice with a
registered letter bring that car in and
we'll fix it for nothing but they killed
three hundred thousand a year nobody
protests as long as we get are as free
and that scares me that attitude in a
rate I've got a bunch of these recall
notices you should have gotten over the
last couple of years we'll go through
them quickly
number one is ulcers how many of you
ever heard that ulcers is caused by
stress okay everybody's heard that if
you don't raise your hand you got
Alzheimer's or your fibbin right well we
knew fifty years ago and in the
veterinary industry that ulcers at least
in pigs was caused by bacteria called
Helicobacter pylori and of course we
couldn't get one of these high priced
stomach surgeons from Mayo Clinic in
fact we always used to yell hold the
Mayo
when they'd say stuff like that
otherwise your pork chops would be $275
a pound to pay for that kind of surgery
and we learned that with a trace mineral
called bismuth and the tetracycline
antibiotic that we could prevent and
cure those stomach ulcers and pigs
without surgery so that's what we did
cost five bucks to cure a pig of stomach
ulcers with bismuth the trace mineral in
tetracycline well the National
Institutes of Health now not the
National Enquirer but the National
Institutes of Health came out in
February 1994 and said ulcers are caused
by a bacteria called Helicobacter pylori
not stress and they can be cured they
actually use the Cure word in this news
release medical researchers never do
that they always say it shows promising
results or may be beneficial they use
the Cure word National Institutes of
Health and they say can be cured with a
combination of the trace mineral bismuth
and tetracycline well for those of you
don't know what business comes in you
can get it from any grocery store or
drugstore it's pink about 295 for an 8
ounce bottle and it's called
pepto-bismol so a teaspoon a day full of
pepto-bismol and some re mice and calf
scowler pellets you can take care of
sores
now you have your choice but you're
gonna treat your own for five bucks or
go get whittled on that's your choice
then what's the number two cause of
death and Americans terrible disease
called cancer right now doctors get
information on cancer you'd think they'd
photocopy that when they send you that
bill they should send you some photo
copies of this stuff well in September
of 1993 the
National Cancer Institute not the
national enquirer but the National
Cancer Institute and the have't Medical
School in Boston did study on cancer
patients and they came out and they said
an anti-cancer diet was found well any
rate they picked China to do this study
because in one province Henan Province
in China they have the highest rate of
cancer in the whole world
they took 29,000 people for five years
in this study and what they did was give
them different vitamins and minerals at
double the recommended daily allowance
for Americans that's a trivial amount
for instance they used vitamin C for one
group and of course the RDA recommended
daily allowance for vitamin C is 60
milligrams double that's gonna be 120
milligrams you can't go into a health
food store and find a vitamin C tablet
or capsule for less than 500 milligrams
for an adult and of course Linus Pauling
the gentleman was two Nobel Prizes says
if you want to prevent and treat cancer
with vitamin C you got to use 10,000
milligrams a day well all the doctors he
used to argue with him back thirty five
years ago were all dead and today Linus
Pauling still 94 and he works 14 hours a
day seven days a week on his ranch in
the Big Sur in California and teaches at
the University of California San
Francisco so you have to make up your
choice whether you're going to listen to
the dead doctors or Linus Pauling your
choice okay vitamin C double the RDA
nothing happened vitamin A double the
RDA nothing happens zinc riboflavin the
trace mineral molybdenum nice and
nothing happened in one group they got a
major benefit in this group they got
three nutrients at one time they got
vitamin E
they got beta-carotene and the trace
mineral selenium there those three were
at double the RDA and if you get a half
a percent benefit in any nutritional or
pharmaceutical experiment you've made a
major improvement in humanity's life and
so these articles get published so I
want to remember that statistic a half a
percent is major benefit well in this
group that received the vitamin D
beta-carotene and selenium for five
years deaths from all causes were
reduced by nine percent almost 10 out of
every hundred or one out of every ten
who were going to die in that five years
from any cause survived then cancers all
cancers thirteen percent survived who
would have died without those three
nutrients
so 13 out of a hundred lived who would
have died and then the type of cancer
that was most prevalent in Henan
Province stomach and esophageal cancer
21 percent lived who would have died 21
out of a hundred lived now to me those
are significant numbers and your
physician for the number two cause of
death in America should have sent every
one of you a photocopy that at least
given the information even if he doesn't
want to give you the advice give you the
information let you make up your own
mind well here's one I think is funny on
one hand and on the other side it tells
you the attitude of physicians this has
to do with arthritis it was in September
24th 1993 that it was released again it
was from the habit Medical School in the
Basten VA hospital how many of you in
here have ever been to a VA hospital
anybody in this room okay good well you
know the people who've been to a VA
hospital we have two opportunities to
give your life for your country
once on the field of battle and the
others in the VA hospital right well
narrate the title of the release was
chicken protein halts to swelling and
pain of arthritis in a patient trial and
what they did they took people who
failed to respond in any way to medical
treatment for arthritis these people got
gold shots mezzo Trek's eight they got
aspirin prednisone cortisone everything
else you can think of physical therapy
and the only thing left for them was
joint replacement surgery okay now
before Harvard Medical School the VA
hospital was going to give it to him
they said look we're looking for some
people who are willing to suffer for 90
more days just three months because we
want to try something a short-term
experiment and they got 29 volunteers
and what they did for those 29
volunteers who failed to respond in any
way to medical treatment for arthritis
was they gave them a heaping teaspoon
full of ground-up dried chicken
cartilage in their orange juice every
morning just a heaping teaspoon of
ground up chicken cartilage and in ten
days according to Harvard Medical School
all the pain and inflammation was gone
these are people who didn't respond in
any way to medical treatment in 30 days
they could open up a new pickle jar that
never been opened and ninety days three
months they had maximum return of
function here's the funny part
the funny part comes by a statement of
the guy who was the director of that
study from Harvard
school here's what he said quote listen
to the words a very important quote
after three months it was clear that the
drug was beneficial unquote because it
worked
chicken cartilage had become a drug you
can see he's thinking about patent
numbers and his eyes are rolling around
with 300 bucks a capsule 20 patients and
did you just see him calculating right
that means if you go to Kentucky Fried
Chicken and you buy a bucket of chicken
throw away the skin and the meat and eat
the ends off the bones you're practicing
medicine without a license and if you go
to a Kentucky Fried Chicken in the
middle of the night and the dark of the
night and you go to their dumpster and
your route through there and you collect
two 5-gallon feed buckets full of
chicken bones and you take them home
with a hammer and you pound off the ends
of those bones and dry your own
cartilage in the microwave you know
you're manufacturing pharmaceutical and
the FDA is gonna put you in jail next
time I come by here in three months
you're gonna run up on this stage and
hug me and kiss me if you got arthritis
how many you've ever heard of alzheimers
disease everybody's heard about it today
50 years ago when I was a little kid
there's no such thing as alzheimers
disease it's a new disease one of those
things that just sort of happened now
it's a major disease one out of every
two people who reach age 70 get
Alzheimer's disease pretty scary we
learned 50 years ago in the animal
industry how to prevent and cure in the
early stages a Alzheimer's disease in
livestock you imagine how much a farmer
would lose if the pigs were all laying
there scratching their heads saying why
am I here
where is the feed box because if they're
not gaining a couple of pounds a day
you're losing money right so we learned
in the agricultural industry how to
prevent in the early stages cure
Alzheimer's disease and we do it with
high doses of vitamin E and low intakes
of vegetable oil you say well like
that's crazy high doses of vitamin E
well you should have got a recall notice
from your doctor in July of 1992 because
the University of California I mean
we're talking about a sophisticated
research medical school here University
of California San Diego came out and
said vitamin E eases memory loss and
Alzheimer's victims there are only 50
years behind on that from veterinary
medicine so we might be safer going to a
veterinarian then how many of you in
this room ever had a kidney stone
anybody in here ever get that kidney
stone okay I see a few in here what's
the first thing a doctor told you to
give up nutritionally when you got your
kidney stone give up calcium no dairy no
dairy
none of those vitamin mineral things
with calcium in them because they have
the stupid naive ignorant belief as
pretty intense they have the stupid
ignorant naive belief that the calcium
in your kidney stone comes from the
calcium you eat when in fact it comes
from your own bones when you have a
raging calcium deficiency a raging
osteoporosis then you get kidney stones
we learned years ago in writing in the
agricultural industry if you wanted to
prevent kidney stones in livestock you
better give them more calcium you better
give them more magnesium and more boron
the reason is of course bulls and rams
male cattle and sheep have special
anatomy when they get a kidney stone
they die they called water belly they
died when you and I get a kidney stone
we just wish we were dead but no farmer
is dumb enough to pay for the feed for
an animal and have it die before you can
either eat it or send it to market so we
learned how to prevent those things well
you should have got a recall notice from
your doctor especially you people who've
had kidney stones your urologist should
have sent a notice to you this was March
of 1993 it says calcium limits kidney
stone risk and this is from the have't
medical school up in Boston by the way
in a study that turns conventional
medical wisdom on its head researchers
have found that people whose diets are
rich in calcium run a reduced risk of
in kidney stones and it's studied more
than 45,000 people though who were
ranked into five categories the group
that had the most calcium had no kidney
stones now about five years ago when I
started out on this crusade and started
lecturing to people all across America
and I'm in one timezone in the next and
all over I knew I was gonna get crazy
out there doing this last year I was on
the road 300 days out of the year 300
out of 365 days and so I decided I
needed to have a hobby that I could take
with me every time I get a little wacko
I could go in my room and do this hobby
and I'd be okay you know be kind of like
to having a little piece of home with me
wherever I went and I wanted to have a
hobby that would help other people I
didn't want to collect baseball cards
because I like football and I didn't
want to do just crossword puzzles
because good mental exercise but
wouldn't help anybody else and I
couldn't take my compost pile I like the
garden and the hotels don't like that
you know so I decided I was going to
collect obituaries of doctors and
lawyers
now as crazy as that sounds remember I
told you the doctors lived to an average
age of 58 and we live to seventy five
point five and here's a group of people
professionals who pontificate you and
tell you well this is what you need to
do you need to give up salt and no
caffeine and you need to not eat butter
and eat margarine and do all these crazy
things and they die at age 58 on the
average anybody got a few of them here
some of my favorites so this dr. Stuart
Cartwright age 38 he dropped dead in his
home he was a family practitioner of a
ruptured aneurysm that's a ballooning of
an artery that's a weakened artery
because of the fragmenting or the
brittle condition of the elastic fibers
and arteries just like when you hit a
chuckhole with your car tire and you
break the cords in there and you get a
balloon he dropped dead like he was
poleaxed okay right in his home from a
ruptured aneurysm and we learned in 19
oh I think it was 57 aneurysms are
caused by a copper deficiency we had a
pilot project turkeys we made complete
food pellets where you put all the 90
nutrients in there and in the first 13
weeks fully half of those turkeys died
farmers were out there every morning
picking them up by the bushel basket
they took them to the state diagnostic
labs and their autopsy they found out
that they all had died from a ruptured
aortic aneurysm so they doubled the
amount of copper in there and the next
year they didn't lose a single turkey
from a ruptured aortic aneurysm and they
ran that experiment in mice and rats and
rabbits and dogs and cats and calves and
sheep and pigs and whatnot and guess
what they found out there's a whole
series of diseases that are caused by a
copper deficiency gray hair is the first
sign we started getting gray hair
regardless of your age you got a copper
deficiency you get skin wrinkles because
the elastic fibers in your skin are
going those little crow's feet around
your eyes and facial and body skin
wrinkles you look like you're a little
prune drying up okay then of course
there's the varicose veins that's caused
by an elastic fiber breakdown then of
course parts of your body begin to sag
under your arms your breasts your
bellies your legs all this stuff start
sagging and you go to a cosmetic surgeon
a plastic surgeon if you want
it's a lot cheaper and a lot more
effective and a lot safer he just takes
some copper dr. Cartwright may have had
a medical degree but he didn't have
expensive urine so he died of something
that even a turkey wouldn't die from
then here's one this fellow he was a
doctor's doctor dr. Martin Carter he
almost made it he died at age 57 he got
his medical degree from have't Medical
School and his PhD in medicine from Yale
he was autopsy by the best because he
was a doctors doctor said quote the
cause of death was a ruptured aortic
aneurysm said dr. Jules Hirsch the
Rockefeller University Hospital unquote
what did he die from copper deficiency
see he didn't have expensive urine
either and here's an attorney
she was so famous she was from Detroit
age 44 Ellen Joyce alter she was in the
New York Times obituary she made the big
time and of course she probably had
steel buns because she belonged to one
of those private health clubs all these
gals want steel buns you know doing
their little exercises but she didn't
have expensive urine because she died of
a ruptured cerebral aneurysm when they
don't do an autopsy the symptoms could
be called a stroke or subdural
hemorrhage but very frequently they're
caused by a ruptured aneurysm which is a
copper deficiency she didn't have
expensive urine how many of you were
here I've ever heard of a guy by the
name of Stewart burger Stewart burger he
he wrote five best-selling books on
health and diets and nutrition he got
his medical degree from Tufts Medical
School which is a very fine Medical
School in Boston not too far away from
Harvard Medical School and the books he
wrote included the Southampton diet for
weight loss
he wrote Forever Young 20 years younger
in 20 weeks and how to be your own
nutritionist and he died at age 40 how'd
you like to follow his dietary practices
he died at age 40 of cardiomyopathy
which is a selenium deficiency the same
causes white muscle disease or our stiff
lamb disease and any farmer can go to a
feed store and get selenium pellets or
selenium injections of things like cell
Atok and Bazzi and so forth and dr.
Stewart burger guy who wrote five
best-selling books on nutrition died of
a nutritional deficiency he didn't have
expensive urine
you can prevent totally prevent
cardiomyopathy for 10 cents a day and if
we don't do it we're malignant dumb I
like to call it your malignant dumb if
you don't take in 10 cents a day worth
of selenium it's a waste of your life
that's one of those landmines you can
avoid the medical treatment of choice
for cardiomyopathy is a heart transplant
caused 750 thousand dollars I want you
to think about that they get the heart
free from a donor they get the blood
free for the surgery from the relatives
these two dollars and fifty cents worth
of suture material and they charges
seven hundred and fifty thousand dollars
for that procedure now six months ago in
LA when they had the earthquake they
were putting people in jail for 60 and
90 days for price gouging for selling
these terrified people a gallon of water
for four dollars they put him in jail
for price gouging for selling him a
gallon of water for four bucks now to me
that's entrepreneurial ISM you know
that's being in business for yourself if
you had a way to distill water and make
water and you had a car and you could
get in there and sell those people a
gallon of water for 4 bucks a more power
to you because if you go to a 7-eleven
and buy a quart of Evian water it's a
dollar twenty nine so four of those
quarts is a five bucks kind of
interesting isn't it
they said it's price gouging because
those people were terrified we'll talk
about a person who needs a new heart
they're terrified 750 thousand dollars
we should put those doctors in jail but
we bow to them because all that's
high-tech medicine our 270 million
people in America you save about 50 a
year is that cost-effective I don't
think so dr. Stuart Berger didn't have
expensive urine here's the last one and
many of you may know this woman her name
is dr. Gail Clark she was aged 47 she
was the chief cardiologist at the West
st. Louis County group of hospitals she
was the chief cardiologist for the st.
Mary's health center in Richmond Heights
in st. Louis County she's aged 47 guess
what she died from heart attack a
cardiomyopathy heart attack you can just
see her walking down the hall she got
the stethoscope around her neck you know
this is their little status symbol got
my stethoscope around my neck back when
I was in school they folded it up very
bravely and put it in their pocket when
she falls down she has a heart attack
right in the hall and of course the
nurses scooped her up and put her on a
gurney and they call the technicians and
another died
code 3 code 3 code blue whatever it is
and they whip her into the room and you
can hear me let's say you're a cardiac
patient you're laying there you're all
hooked up to the monitors and the IVs
and and you hear them say okay tear
clothes off okay stand back didn't work
turn it up stand back and then you hear
that terrible sound when you know that
the treatment didn't work the flatline
when you know the heart is gone and
everybody walks out of the room dejected
and you say nurse nurse what happened
next door and she says well your
cardiologist you know the chief
cardiologist to this hospital age 47 dr.
Gail Clark just died of a cardiac
monitor you heart attack we can see all
the patients are holding their gowns and
they're running out of that hospital
leaving their watches and their shoes
and their checkbooks and everything
their plastic credit cards because they
don't want to get with dr. Gail Clark
got to me the Reader's Digest is a
magazine that never says anything
negative or bad about anybody or any
group it's a sweetest little magazine
that ever was the September 1993 issue
features an article it says can you
trust your doctor
it lists 12 ways the doctors scam your
money and I'll let you read 11 them
yourself I'll give you the worst one in
addition to their income from office
fees and surgical fees and lab fees and
hospitalization doctors get a kickback
from the labs and the the x-ray labs and
clinics and hospitals they get a
kickback of 421 dollars every time they
send you in for a cat scan or an MRI and
doctors tell you all we do that because
we're practicing defensive medicine
because if I miss something
you know one in ten billion you're gonna
sue me so I do this just to protect
myself well if it was just to protect
themselves and you knew them and they
knew you ninety percent of the people
say oh I'll just skip it doc if you
don't really think it's necessary let's
save the money but they got something
more than defensive medicine to worry
about they get four hundred and
twenty-one bucks in a kickback for every
time they send you in for an MRI or a
cat scan well when I practice for twelve
years up in Portland somebody come to me
with a terrible headache never had one I
just walk up to him and tap him on the
sinuses and if they collapsed to their
knees I know they had a sinus headache
Oh doc why did you do that well Isparta
that's a cheap lab test you
then if they had thank you if they had
blood dripping out of their nose that
take a $35 x-ray to see if they had a
cancer in their 35 bucks in a free lab
test as opposed to 421 bucks if I wanted
to make that 421 bucks I'd have been a
good thief what I'd have done I to build
a chute right into that cat scan machine
because I knew how to build shoots
living on a farm and I did going out in
the street and I got every homeless
person I'd line them up in them chutes
and I'd put soup and a Big Mac at the
end of that tube you know and I say I'm
gonna get by you a dollar 50 dinner I'm
a good guy I'm gonna buy you a dollar 50
dinner you just got to go through this
chute go through that tube and you get
your sandwich in your soup man they'd be
flowing through there maybe a hundred a
day and I can start adding some things
up it'd be a lot of fun any rate the
average doctor gets two hundred and
twenty eight thousand six hundred and
sixty dollars a year in cat-scan
kickbacks a quarter of a million dollars
a year and any other industry if you do
that politicians lawyers businessmen
stockbrokers they got put in jail but
doctors it's okay because insurance pays
for it we don't mind if they steal is
blind it's free remember I told you I
was gonna tell you about Piko Piko is a
funny disease P I ca I'm going to talk
about the type style that you see in
typewriters and computers but Pike is a
disease that farmers know about in
horses it's called cribbing when they
chew on the feed bunk the wooden feed
bunk
you know you better give them some
minerals otherwise or and eat that feed
bunk and cattle dairy cattle especially
they're losing lots of minerals through
their milk all the time intensive
milking you'll see them picking up big
rocks in the creek and chewing on them
or they'll chew on Bob wire or maybe
you'll see them walking down through a
path with a deer bone in their mouth or
something or a shingle
that's called pika and a good farmer
husbandry man knows you better give them
some minerals otherwise they're gonna
eat the barn or something in human
beings we see this at funny times
pregnant women are notorious for Piko
the middle of the night they'll elbows
their husband and say hey you better get
up I want some pickles and ice cream
they're craving minerals because that
fetus is pulling minerals out of their
body they need some more minerals and so
it's recognized as a craving for things
like sweets and salt we see this in
pregnant women I used to have
people come to my practice and they say
doctor I need to go see a shrink I said
why is that well I wake up in the middle
of the night and I go outside with a
spoon and I eat dirt no that's okay
just make sure it's clean dirt then they
say my kid sits there with a kitty
litter box between his legs and he has a
spoon and he's eating that stuff I the
kitty litter box and then in housing
projects little kids will eat lead paint
off the walls and they get lead
poisoning at learning disabilities and
bone problems in Annie Mia and we're
good so we spend five million dollars to
scrape the lead paint off of there and
repaint it with latex paint we only have
just give those kids ten cents a day
worth of minerals would be better farm
and save us five million bucks
it's your tax money and if we allow them
to throw them away those dollars is kind
of interesting if you have a selenium
deficiency and you don't want to wait
until you get to cardiomyopathy and drop
dead from a heart attack to recognize it
if you look on your hands and look in
the mirror in your face if you have
liver spots or age spots and I see quite
a few from here you have an early
selenium deficiency that's called free
radical damage and fortunately for you
if you recognize that and you start
taking in some selenium in four to six
months those will go away you'll reverse
that in four to six months and when they
go away on the outside they're going
away on the inside and your brain and
your heart and your liver and your
kidneys and if you have low blood sugar
how many in this room have a low blood
sugar or anybody in here have a low
blood sugar okay about ten percent how
many of you ever seen a hyperactive kid
who gets on sugar okay about everybody
in the room people who have sugar
problems are like alcoholics there's
good ones and bad ones
you know the good alcoholics are one
when they get two drinks they just go
off in a corner and go to sleep right
same way that somebody with low blood
sugar they eat a big meal or they eat a
piece of pie three hours later they
clunk out and go to sleep
then there's bad alcoholics or the one
that gets two drinks in them and they
get violent and raged and they want to
fight everybody punch holes in the wall
you know big brave fellows and they kick
their wife and kick the dog and take the
chainsaw and cut their neighbors tree
down and all these wild things and drive
reckless down the roads and kill people
those are the bad drunks well people who
have blood sugar problems there's bad
blood sugar people to be a little crazy
okay I don't know how many of you
remember the Twinkie defense
right remember if somebody murdered two
people
and he claimed he ate a Twinkie three
hours before he murdered them so they
let him off because he got temporarily
insane every time he ate sugar now don't
any of you try that
well chromium and vanadium deficiency
will result in these sugar problems low
blood sugar if you let it go on for any
length of time you develop diabetes
chromium and vanadium
then attend to fish and see the early
symptoms of a10 deficiency our male
pattern baldness I see a lot of 10
deficiency in this room yes and if you
let it go on for any length of time you
get deafness then there's a boron
deficiency and you gouge had know about
boron because it helps you keep the
calcium you take in and your bones so
you don't get osteoporosis boron also it
helps you make estrogen it helps you
fellas make testosterone if you don't
take in enough boron you ladies are
gonna suffer miserably going through
menopause okay you're gonna have all
those terrible symptoms you fellas don't
get enough boron can't make testosterone
you won't know whether to lead or follow
on the dance floor
you're gonna be confused she's saying
he's got a boron deficiency the first
symptoms of a zinc deficiency as you
lose your sense of smell and your taste
say oh you know food just doesn't taste
good anymore you don't have a cold or
anything like that you say your wife
says well aren't you excited about
dinner I spent the whole day in the
kitchen cooking dinner he says I didn't
smell anything when I walked in you know
he's got a zinc deficiency when
laboratory animals there's some seven
rare earths these rare earths or trace
minerals you need in lesser amounts that
you need trace minerals and they
actually double the lifespan of
laboratory animals they've not been
proven in humans yet but I'm not going
to wait five hundred years for doctors
to approve it they're still arguing over
vitamin C and calcium right so I'm just
going to do it didn't kill any
laboratory animals just doubles her life
and it's not a drug these rare earths
are called lanthanum precio die Miam
neodymium samarium europium ytterbium
and thulium there must be a reason why
they're named after old testament cities
well remember I told you we needed 90
nutrients we need 60 minerals we need 16
vitamins 12 essential amino acids and
three essential fatty acids and of
course we're lucky in that plants as a
group can make most vitamins amino acids
and fatty acids plants can do that
because they just take carbon out of the
air and make carbon chains to make
vitamins amino acids and fatty acids but
you have to eat 15 to 25 different
plants a day in the right combinations
to make this happen theoretically as
possible but most Americans don't do it
the average American thinks if they eat
some potato buds out of a Betty Crocker
box or eaten a vegetable in case oh you
got to be careful what you're
considering a vegetable then of course
people want to do right by their doctor
and they eat low-fat turkey breasts and
they put a half a jar of mayonnaise on
there and they put it between two slices
of wonder styrofoam bread remember that
stuff you can insulate your house with
and put your shoes when you get a whole
and shoe I remember when I was a kid
there's a lot of fun because we have
Wonder Bread we didn't have TVs back
then on the farm we didn't even have
dryers that went round and round so the
only thing you could do in the
wintertime was sit in the kitchen and
wonder
a loaf of Wonder Bread and a head the
blue and red and green yellow balloons
on there and if you read the label as
many times as I do you know it said
things like helps build bodies at 12
weighs in about 15 years later the FDA
made them change it to help build your
body eight ways now if you go to the
store and look at Wonder bread wrappers
it just says Wonder Bread so it kind of
gives you a clue so even though this is
theoretically possible it's not likely
to happen that you're going to get your
vitamins amino acids and fatty acids and
proper proportions from your diet and so
if your life is as valuable to you as
mine is to me and my children's and my
grandchildren's is to me I would make
sure that I take in all my vitamins and
amino acids and fatty acids because I
guarantee you won't make it to 122 if
you don't you're just not going to do it
now minerals are another story we have a
tragic story when it comes to minerals
because plants cannot make minerals in
any way shape or form and if they're not
in the soil anymore they're not in our
plants there are farms oils and our rain
soils are depleted of minerals in the
crops the grains the fruits and the
vegetables and the nuts that are grown
on these depleted farm and rain soils or
mentally deficient the people eat them
get mineral deficiency diseases and the
only way to prevent and cure them is
with mineral supplements do you think
it's gotten any better no it has not
gotten any better it's only gotten worse
and the reason is if you guys do what we
did and people continue to do is we put
NPK on our land nitrogen phosphorus
potassium and you see it as these three
numbers in many combinations of ratios
and these represent percentages of these
three nutrients nitrogen phosphorus
potassium and those of you who don't
have any experience on farms the reason
why we do this as farmers get paid for
tons and bushels
there's no subsidy that encourages
people to put 60 minerals back in the
soil you get paid for tongues and
bushels and for 40 bucks an acre you can
get the maximum yield in tons and
bushels it only takes five to ten years
to deplete the land of minerals because
every time you harvest a crop those
plants pull minerals out of the soil
many pounds per acre every time you haul
a crop out so as soon those minerals are
gone and if you only put back in three
and you take out sixty it's like a
checking account if you only put three
bucks in your checking it
every month and write checks for 60
what's going to happen to your checks
Boeing Boeing Boeing they bounce exactly
well I can tell you that our health is
bouncing right now to the tune of 1.2
trillion dollars a year it's our
responsibility each and every one of us
to be responsible for our health and
consciously take in these minerals I
have a lot of people ask me what did
these people do thousands of years ago
they didn't even have commercial
fertilizers what did they do these
societies that had long lived people and
whatnot but I want you to think about
the Egyptians the Chinese people from
India that lived around these great
rivers the Nile River the Ganges River
the Yellow River in China and what used
to happen was every year or so would
flood just like it did here in northern
Missouri last year and every time it
flooded guess what would happen it would
bring silt or rock dust from mountains
from five hundred or thousand miles away
and those people would pray to every God
they had the water God the sky god the
wind God the rock God to flood we pray
don't flood they used to pray to flood
because they had their floods during the
wintertime and it would put silt and
minerals back in the soil and their
drain was very valuable King Phillip
who's the father of Alexander the Great
married the 12 year old child queen of
Egypt Cleopatra she didn't look like
Elizabeth Taylor all made up in
beautiful costumes she was a little
flat-chested teeny bopper not very sexy
but Philip married her because she
controlled the best wheat in the world
and if he wanted his Macedonian army to
conquer the world through his son
Alexander the Great he needed the best
wheat in the world so you could march 20
hours a day fight for six hours and win
if they used the wheat from the depleted
soils in Greece they couldn't go 20
minutes without saying mommy pick me up
do you imagine these big Greek soldiers
oh my legs hurt pick me up and so they
knew the best place to get wheat was
from Egypt it was those floods that gave
him those minerals and all those
cultures that came up with all the great
art and all the great technology came
from those places because they had more
intelligence because they had more
nutrition more minerals I heard somebody
say very good well you're getting the
picture
well what I'm gonna do here is I'm just
gonna pick out a couple of minerals just
a couple of them so you get the idea
it applies to all of them let's just
pick out a common one
like calcium everybody knows about
calcium calcium deficiency will result
in something like a hundred and forty
seven different diseases they're just
different names are named after people
like Bell's palsy you know everybody
knows about that one side of your face
sags it's not as true stroke it just
affects your facial muscles it's caused
by a calcium deficiency we'll talk about
in a little bit but everybody knows
about this one osteoporosis it's the
number 10 killer of adults the United
States it's a very expensive it cost you
thirty five thousand dollars each for
each hip to replace it's okay it's free
insurance will pay for it cost you
seventy thousand dollars for both hips
as expensive as it is and the number ten
killer remember mister Skeets from
Radford Virginia ages one hundred and
fifteen years of age he died of
complications of a fall we don't have
osteoporosis and animals and it's
because of farmers we don't have
osteoporosis and animals goes like this
you have a pasture with a hundred cows
in it and this year you didn't have any
calves you can't repay your operating
loan you're in trouble right because you
paid for the feed and the vet bill and
mowed the pasture and fertilize and
maintain the fence and fed the cows and
all this that in the other you don't
have any calves you can't pay back the
operating loan and make any money so you
call the vet out you say do I get rid of
these cows what happened here and he
examines the college there's nothing
wrong with them says let me look at the
bull and says aha here's your problem
that bull has osteoporosis of both hips
can't breed the cows didn't have any
calves he says I'll tell you what though
he says you give me $70,000 he says I'll
put two new hips in that bull next year
you'll have some calves well the first
thing that farmer says to stand back doc
well he blows that bull away with a deer
rifle and well the kids are grinding the
bull up with a grinder and cutting
roasts and steaks off that bull the
farmers chewing on a straw and saying
now doc pushes Stetson up a little bit
and he says you know I wasn't gonna pay
you seventy thousand dollars for that
old boys I could get a new bull every
year for seventy years for that he says
but every once while I get a bullet
throws good calves I'd like to keep him
is there any way I can prevent that
osteoporosis thing for happen to a good
boy says well yeah he says if you'll
give a bull calf ten cents worth of
calcium every day after he's weaned
he'll never get osteoporosis firms in oh
wait a minute doc you mean if I give
that bull ten
a day worth of calcium from the time
he's weaned I can prevent a $70,000
disaster oh yeah it's that simple
he says you mean I only have to do is
give up a half a cup of coffee a day to
do that he says yeah that's it he says I
choose that one he's I'll give up the
half a cup of coffee and that's what we
have to think like then there's receding
gums dentist and periodontist will tell
you that if you want to prevent and cure
receding gums you better floss and brush
after every meal if you believe that
works I have some oceanfront property in
Montana to sell you if you all know your
geography you know that doesn't work now
as a veterinarian I've seen hundreds of
thousands of animals of all kinds mice
rats rabbits dogs can't sheep pigs
horses lines and tigers and bears and
they don't get receding gums and they
don't floss now they do get funky breath
but they don't get receding gums well if
you want to smell some you just let a
camel breathe it on you boy well the
reason we don't have receding gums in
livestock is because we've dealt with
the osteoporosis problem receding gums
is not a deficiency of flossing it's in
fact osteoporosis of the jaw bones and
of the facial bones so if you have Ginja
Vitus or receding gums you have advanced
osteoporosis those bones around your
teeth are melting away a little bit by a
little bit every day and if you take
your teeth out at night and put them in
a glass next to your bed and that fizzy
stuff you have major advanced
osteoporosis because all your bone has
melted away
then there's arthritis we talked about
that a little bit earlier remember the
chicken cart leaves 85% of all arthritis
is caused by a steeper osis of the joint
ends of the bones you're talking about
degenerative arthritis osteoarthritis
sciatica lumbago rheumatism all those
sorts of things they're caused by
osteoporosis of the joint ends of the
bones I want you to think about
something for a minute if you don't take
a pain reliever or an anti-inflammatory
for that arthritis let's say you get
arthritis of the hips you're gonna kind
of favor that a little bit aren't you
you're gonna get a cane or a walker or
crutches
you're gonna favor it and so you don't
put any weight on it I want you to think
about that for just a second because
then I want you to think about driving
your tractor in a field or you're
driving a Mercedes down the highway
either one doesn't matter
whichever you love more
let's say you didn't put the nut on that
oil pan real tighten all the oil drained
out and that light on the dashboard
comes on says I'm getting hot you better
give me some oil and that light
irritates you so you stop you open up
the hood you get your Clippers out you
know your fence clippers and you clip
the wire to that light you close the
hood and you just keep driving would you
do that to your tractor your Mercedes no
you would we take those pain relievers
for arthritis and we go out there and
square dance and do the Texas two-step
and do our five mile walks in our
aerobics that pill works real good doc
because it killed my pain and you're
just wearing that thing off faster and
faster then your doctor is really gonna
get rich because you need joint
replacement surgery then there's
hypertension this is one of my favorites
so I'll put a star over here
hypertension is high blood pressure
what's the first nutritional thing that
a doctor will tell you to give up
nutritionally when you get high blood
pressure give up salt everybody knows
that when that's been ingrained in our
head well they must think we're dumber
than cows because what's the first thing
you put out for your livestock and about
that big a salt block no farmer is gonna
be economically viable if you don't put
a salt block out for your livestock
they're gonna die kind of your
veterinary bills are gonna go crazy but
we're supposed to believe that we don't
need salt you can get everything you
need out of your lettuce and your
whole-wheat bread and stuff like that
well don't believe that one either if
you believe that I got some more
oceanfront property in Montana for you
they took 30 million dollars of your tax
money and two years ago after 20 years
study they came out and said that they
took 5,000 people with high blood
pressure they took them off their
medication and put him on a reduced salt
diet a restricted salt diet and they all
died no big surprise but somebody got a
PhD degree and everybody was happy right
but when they looked at this results
they said that only ninety-nine point
seven percent the people didn't get any
results from that before they died 0.3
percent did get some result drop their
blood pressure one point before they
died by restricting their salt so the
referees who judged that article said oh
doesn't matter you might as well let
high blood pressure patients heat salted
peanuts and dill pickles and salt their
food to taste because it doesn't matter
in fact worrying about the salt is more
stress than taking the salt then they
had a control group with 5,000 people
with high blood pressure and they
doubled their RDA of calcium
and they stopped the experiment in six
weeks because 85% of them were cured of
their high blood pressure just by
doubling their calcium intake now they
didn't cold turkey stop their high blood
pressure medication but what they did
was they went to the doctor and says you
don't need this medication anymore what
are you doing well I'm on this
experiment I double my calcium intake
anybody get a recall notice from your
doctors saying it's okay to salt your
food to taste and please do double your
calcium intake anybody get that not a
single one is very interesting then of
course there's insomnia that's where you
roll around all night when you wake up
in the morning you're more tired when
you went to bed that's insomnia of
course doctors have two treatments for
that they have Halcyon which is a
sleeping pill and they have barbiturates
they kill about 10,000 people a year
with overdoses of those things but
that's okay it's a prescription and
they're watching out for us
and remember George Bush when he went to
Japan they gave him some healthy on so
he could sleep on the way to Japan
because of the time difference and when
he woke up one of the side effects of
Halcyon is nausea and vomiting I don't
know how you say it in Japanese but it
was very dramatic on world TV right not
very presidential blood and so I'm sure
that's why he lost the election because
he puked over that Japanese ambassador
and then of course there's kidney stones
and then there is a bone spurs heel
spurs and calcium deposits again
physicians will tell you the first thing
to give up nutritionally is calcium and
dairy because they have this foolish
belief the stupid belief the ignorant
belief that the calcium in kidney stones
bone spurs heel spurs and calcium
deposits come from their diet when
instead it only comes from your bones
when you have a raging osteoporosis and
when you get these things you need more
calcium not less then there's cramps and
twitches you wake up in the middle of
the night and your foot is all cramped
up around your neck you say Lord take me
from the knee down I'm not going to make
it till morning we've all experienced
that that's very common
then there's PMS premenstrual syndrome
you know he's the emotional and physical
stuff the medical treatment of choice
for PMS is what we call a hysterical
ectomy it's been shortened to
hysterectomy
that's a hundred-year-old
the doctors do about 285,000 unnecessary
hysterical ectomy a year but it makes
Mercedes payments so they do them even
the AMA said they're unnecessary but
they don't take their licenses away and
people keep going to them you imagine a
poor woman in her 30s she says doc you
got to do something every time I go out
to hang up the clothes my neighbor's
kids run down the basement screaming
which my own kids think I'm crazy my
husband's leaving me I'm gonna lose my
job you got to do something well the
University of California San Diego came
out three years ago now and said if you
just double the RDA of calcium intake
you'll get rid of 85% of the emotional
and physical symptoms of PMS and when
that came out there were huge lines
around the health food stores around the
blocks and people had sleeping bags
because it closed before they all got
their calcium and every person in line
was a man
they were there for their daughters and
their girlfriends and their wives and
things like that okay and lastly is low
back pain 85% of Americans get low back
pain with your work on a computer or you
unload hay or you drive big trucks
doesn't matter low back is a big problem
low back is just osteoporosis of the
vertebra whether you have a disc problem
or what not because if your disc doesn't
have anything to hold on to your
vertebrae have melted away what's going
to happen to the discs especially if you
have a copper deficiency because they're
made out of elastic fibers they go like
a water balloon with a lot of pressure
on them I just want you to look at this
quickly before we do the last mineral
low back you go to an orthopedic surgeon
or rheumatologist you might get a muscle
relaxant you might get valium and a
muscle relaxant you get the laminectomy
you get your vertebrae fuse you might
get a disc operation they don't tell you
75 percent of time you'll never be the
same again right
PMS you go to your ob/gyn you can go to
an internist you can go to a family
counselor or a shrink or divorce
attorney cramps and twitches you go to a
neurologist you go to a sports medicine
doctor an internist
bone spurs heel spurs calcium deposits
you go to a Rheumatologist an orthopedic
surgeon or a podiatrist kidney stones
you go to a urologist or an internist or
a surgeon insomnia you go to shrinker a
sleep clinic or an internist
hypertension you go to a cardiologist
and internist or a surgeon arthritis a
Rheumatologist a orthopedic surgeon or
an internist receding gums you go to a
dentist or a periodontist osteoporosis
you go to all those health specialists
including a tum salesman for nothing
more than a calcium deficiency it cost
you ten cents a day to deal with now on
the average because Americans have
insurance and we have Medicare and
Medicaid we spend on the average $25,000
to two hundred and fifty thousand
dollars and we undergo five to ten
surgical procedures a year for a calcium
deficiency we beg the doctors to do it
we beg the doctors to do it well it's
our choice the last one I'll share with
you is diabetes
everybody is touched by diabetes it's
the number three cause of death in
adults the United States number three
cause of death
and it has terrible complications and
side effects diabetes the side effects
include blindness of many kinds then
there's a kidney failure with dialysis
and kidney transplant there's
cardiovascular disease of all kinds of
course that contributes the number one
cause of death then there is amputations
everybody ought to have one of those
because they're totally paid for in
their health thing because they assume
that you're not just gonna get one
because you want to get everything on
your health benefits and then you
shorten your life because if you have
diabetes on the average you have a
shorter life span than someone who
doesn't have diabetes now we learned in
1957 in the animal industry that we
could prevent and cure diabetes with -
trace minerals has a pretty profound
statement we could prevent and cure
diabetes with - trace minerals in 1957
in animals it was published in
Federation proceedings which is the
Official Journal of the American science
the National Institutes of Health the
official monthly journal is August 1957
well the - trace minerals that you can
get to prevent and cure this are
chromium and vanadium vanadium alone
according to the University of Vancouver
British Columbia Medical School vanadium
alone will replace insulin in antal
onset diabetics which represent 85% of
all diabetics of course they can't quit
their insulin cold-turkey they got to
gradually wean off of it takes four to
six months for most people to slowly
wean off of insulin if they're taking in
adequate amounts of chromium and
vanadium now to me this is criminal
because if you write to hills packing
company that makes science dot dog for
the right over here in Topeka Kansas so
they manufacture signs diet dog food and
other signs diet probably high tech
foods for animals if you write them and
say how many minerals exactly is in
science diet for dog food they'll write
you back and say there's 40 minerals
you're right checkerboard square in st.
Louis Ralston Korean say just how many
minerals are in your rat pellets for
laboratory rats and they'll say there's
28 minerals
I'll give anybody in this room a crisp
new hundred-dollar bill if you can find
me a human infant formula and a grocery
store that has more than 11
so our dogs get 40 minerals that's what
Mike Murphy was saying dog never seems
to get sick because he's getting this
canned dog food with all these vitamins
and minerals
so our dogs get 40 minerals our rats get
28 minerals and our human infants get 11
is that fair no that's called fraud
doesn't matter if you're talking about
SMA Similac Isom l pro soy b fact that's
why they call Similac Similac because it
lacks everything okay if I've convinced
you that you have to consciously take in
all the minerals yourself that you can't
depend on your food and certainly can't
depend on anything that's boxed or
packaged or bottled there's three types
of minerals that you have to be
concerned about one is metallic minerals
and metallic minerals are essentially
ground up rocks metallic minerals are
things like oyster shell eggshell
dolomite limestone calcium carbonate
clays of various kinds mount marula
Knight clay sea bed minerals tums
they're only eight to 12 percent
absorbable when you reach age 35 to 40
it drops down to three to five percent
and I have to tell you a story here I
ran into a guy at a meeting like this up
at Grand Rapids Michigan and this fella
owns a port-a-potty business you know
that's that green or blue colored
outhouse man if we had only had one of
those back when I was a kid we had these
ones with splinters you know in the wood
he said I see something that that
describes that my port-a-potty business
I said what's that
he says when we take those things back
to the shop to clean him out with the
pressure hose he says we put a quarter
inch grid underneath him because kids
throw rocks and sticks and toys in there
and if we don't put a grid there it
blocks up the sewer system it cost us
thousands of dollars to fix it every
time we clean one of those out we find
hundreds of vitamin tablets and said
well how do you know they're vitamin
tablets he said well that's really easy
he says right on the coating it says
teragrams em one a day Centrum
he says come here and he takes me out in
the back of the shop and there's his
literal mountain of all these vitamin
pills he got out of his porta-potties if
you read the labels on those multiples
they say your iron that comes in the
form of iron oxide what is iron oxide
rust you might as well just go out to an
old railroad track and take your butter
knife and scrape some of that rust off
and lick it and you're gonna get your
iron supplement that's what there
I'll show you how bad it is if you take
something like calcium lactate which is
a common metallic mineral let's say it's
a calcium tab of calcium lactate a
thousand milligrams if you take two of
those you're not getting two thousand
milligrams of calcium in fact I have
people all the time say well I took lots
of calcium doc I hear you on the radio
talking about calcium and arthritis and
I took two thousand milligrams of
calcium a day didn't help my Earthrise
in fact it got worse as to what kind of
calcium you taken
they said calcium lactate well there is
your problem because only 250 milligrams
of that is metallic calcium so let's say
absorb 10% of that then the other 750
milligrams is lactose or milk sugar so
10% of 250 is 25 so if you take two of
those tablets you're not getting 2,000
you're getting 50 milligrams so to get
what you need you need to take 90 of
those tablets a day you need to take 30
with each meal and you got 59 more
minerals to go then there's those people
who want to do things naturally let's
see if you can do anything good with 10
pounds of spinach and let's be fair
let's see if you get a thousand
milligrams of magnesium and I pick
magnesium and because in green leafy
vegetables you have a lot of magnesium
because of the chlorophyll rights part
of the chlorophyll molecule and any
pound of anything you got 454 grams and
10 pounds of spinach you got 4500 and 40
grams of which most of that 97% is water
unless they have one gram of chlorophyll
in that 10 pounds of spinach there's 50
milligrams of magnesium you got to
divide that into the thousand you want
you get a factor of 20 which you
multiply times the 10
you have to eat 200 pounds of spinach
you got 58 more minerals to go okay so
you got to be a pretty big person to
accomplish all this even as big as I am
you can't get it done so I preferred a
supplemental rather than do those things
then of course during the 60s the
agricultural industry came up with
chelated minerals because farmers aren't
dumb enough to pay for a dollar if
something goes into an animal's mouth
and have 99 cents come out in the manure
I have to really thank farmers for being
that clever and chelated minerals are
just metallic minerals with an amino
acid or protein or enzyme
wrapped around the metal atom and
increase the absorbability to 40% then
the health food industry jumped on that
right away because it was a major
improvement absorbability of minerals
the most efficient way to absorb
minerals is liquid they're very small
particle size are seven thousand times
smaller than a red blood cell and their
negatively charged so you actually have
an electrical or magnetic gradient that
concentrates these minerals plants have
a very interesting part to play in
colloidal minerals remember we said that
plants cannot create minerals they're
not in the soil plants can't make them
any rate metallic minerals are taken up
by plants when they're in the soil
plants convert them in their tissues to
colloidal minerals and this is how we
store minerals in our body this is how
we use minerals in our body this is how
we transport minerals from the storage
place to their site of use in the
colloidal farm
well our plants our crops don't have
much in the way of colloidal minerals in
them because we don't have any metallic
minerals in our soil there are these
minerals important you bet your life
they're important information and
statements regarding dietary supplements
discussed have not been evaluated by the
Food and Drug Administration and are not
intended to diagnose treat cure or
prevent any disease for more information
get back with the person who gave you
this